I said it.
I said it right there.
I was like,
"You a woman."
- Mm-hmm.
- "I'm a man."
- There's a difference--
Oh, what?
They bumpin' niggas
up in here.
Here it is.
It's going off.
Yo!
Hey!
Which one of y'all
motherfuckers...
bumped me?
I did.
What the fuck you gonna do
about it?
What's up?
Oh, I'll tell you
what I'ma do about it!
You don't want
to do this today.
Ooh, yeah.
Yeah, what?
You lucky my friend's
holding me.
You lucky,
'cause I'll tear your head off!
Don't hold me back, dude!
Don't hold me back!
Oh, okay.
Then go for it.
See, I know, though,
if I were to lunge
at you right now,
my friend right here--
he'd catch me
at the last
possible second--
No, no,
no, I won't.
But my friend does have
the cognizance
to tell me I don't need
to be going up
and committing capital murder
up in a club tonight.
Oh, no, just knock him
unconscious, dog.
Bam!
You don't have
to kill anybody.
I mean, no need for that.
That's excessive.
Tear him up.
I will, but--
[stammering]
Wait. Let me finish my sentence.
I will, uh...
Oh!
Oh, snap.
You know what?
You lucky my boy's using
his telekinetic powers
to hold me back
right now.
No, I'm not.
Well, maybe it's the type
of telekinesis
that's a mutant power that you
didn't realize you had
until the moment it--
Oh, oh!
I got it.
I see, I see.
So you want me
to hold you back.
Nigga...
[screaming]
I'm a dragon.
Oh, yeah,
I want to rip this.
I'm a lion.
I'm a tiger over here.
I'm a bear.
Oh, my.
I'll go crazy
on you.
Oh, I can't believe it.
The man--he's like a tornado
up in here.
Don't hold me back.
I can't even believe
I can hold him back.
Do it, man!
I can't believe
I'm this strong!
Let me go!
I'm one-arming it.
I can't believe I'm this strong.
Let me go!
I'ma hold him back
with one finger.
He's like a little baby.
He can't get past me.
He's like a little--Ow!
What?
- I'm a little baby?
- I'm holding you back, man!
- You're stupid, man!
- I know.
I got carried away.
I apologize.
What you mean
you got carried away?
You told me to hold you back.
I was holding you back.
What do you
want me to do?
In a fight situation,
no means no,
and yes means yes.
How would
I have known that?
Oh, wait.
Come on, man, ow.
Come on, that hurt.
And you holding me
back now?
Thank you
very much for that.
Okay, well,
just at least change it up.
Okay, now
you listen.